all right
alex alex uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
um pica rivera yeah
suburb of l.a and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were growing up now growing up is my
mother my grandmother my
great-grandmother
daddy's in prison you know uh no no tell
father figures just about
just women raised by women and uh
and how was your childhood um
it was all right you know it was i don't
have too many bad memories of it
but uh uh now that i'm older the
backlash uh
lacked a lot of affection and uh you
joined the gang at what age
about 14 i became a football member yeah
and you're uh you've done prison time i
assume right that's right
when did that start for you uh we'll
start with sergeant general i'm 13 14
years old you mean
and you know when i was 17 uh i was
around my older homeboys people that
mean dudes were like 25 26 years old you
know
and uh i started doing our robberies
with them and you started doing like
robe
heavier crimes you know i was doing
heavier crimes with older jimmy so i was
prisoner 18.
yeah and uh so
that means uh y.a at that point no state
prison or prison i'm going to say prison
at 17 yeah 17 years eight months they
convicted me
what was that for uh laying weight
attended murder
attempted murder and laying weight
parked down we parked the front of his
house away from waiting for
waiting for anybody to come in out of
the house to jump out and get him okay
so how many years did you do i did year
10 months
16 years so i mean prison kind of you
were in and out i assume
uh i did my 16 years straight got out
i stood out probably three years uh you
know i had kids nearly stood out
and then um i started [ __ ] around my
neighborhood around again started
hanging out with my neighbor again
instead just you know and
i started violating and just just you
know spiraled all back down again
yeah now i'm back running around the
streets again you've been after how many
years
uh since 2014.
and the did that lifestyle affect your
like do you have family do you have kids
do you have
life well i i didn't have my family
after i got out of prison
but yeah it doesn't say no now it's
affecting you it
has faked my my relationship with my
wife my kids are here yeah did you raise
your kids were you there
from from the from all through the
pregnancies with my son and daughter i
was at the pregnancies
i was hurt my daughter was four and my
son was uh three we're going on three
that's when we
broke up okay yeah and uh
looking back at your life i mean do you
have regrets of this oh yeah
yeah i'm at regrets but same time i'm
like [ __ ] yeah i did it i chose this
lifestyle i mean so i'm doing it you
know i mean
what more can i say other than i mean
you know you're still doing it
and i run around still yeah yeah and
uh so the drugs come into the picture
for you at some point
um in prison you know prior to prison i
was i wasn't
too having to drugs you know but uh in
prison there's not much to do you know i
mean you're sitting in a cell
you know i do all my time level four one
eighty you know i mean last time you
slammed down
so it's like um it's one of the only
things to do is like one of those one of
the escapes i guess you'd say you know
yeah
and uh was it heroin heroin yeah that's
that's that seems to be the go-to drug
for the yeah we're not sure i put you up
for the day you know kills the whole day
because time you know just
you know so what what kind of uh
what kind of stories can you tell oh man
no man
i'm sure you've got more than you do i
mean some
you know like foul ones to some they're
just like
[Music]
you know it depends what you give you
the most horrifying story you got
you can be vague about some details if
you need to protect you
um all right so i was i was i was a
porter
you know a janitor in the buildings and
uh
we're waiting for someone to come back
and visit and he's bringing in the
opening away from everybody's waiting to
get back
for uh my door stays cracked open
because i go in and out on the quarter
so when the dude goes back to the visit
i go straight over there i'm like hey
he's like well hold on let me let me do
my thing first come back in a half hour
so i was like man
i come back in half hour and he's dead
he's you know he's going to me
and i'm like damn let's do some go call
call someone who's waiting for another
guy right hey man come here
what do we do and he was like [ __ ] how
long has it been like this i don't know
what to do back in half hour and i came
back in a half hour and that's how i
found him
he said where's the dope ass i don't
know where the dope is at and he was
like what do you
don't know i don't know what the [ __ ]
dopes at i don't know we didn't have no
dope
so we looked around real quick for dope
we couldn't find him so this dude oh
dude about 50 snapped his feet he was
[ __ ] still inside him
and i was like all right well okay well
he was like
get some gloves and i was like get some
gloves i guess gloves
so first you get gloves and then he's
like go break some razors
i'm like what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do say we gotta get that out
of his ass and i was like we need to get
our disasters we're gonna cut his ass
open and put the glove a [ __ ] glove
on and i'm gonna get the top of his ass
that's what we did you know and that was
pretty [ __ ] foul you know
it was just like uh
it was experience to me it was just for
dope just to get that stupid dope with
me and we got trouble behind it at the
end of the day anyway i mean they were
you know yeah that was the room
that was uh my bad memories in prison
you know
it wasn't it wasn't good but that was in
prison that was prison yeah
and that's is the gang life in prison
how is that i mean i know it's different
but how is it different than uh
outside um on the street
you know your homeboys in the streets
you're not only homeboys you're friends
and you're a lot of women school with
them you have friendships with them you
know their families and stuff like this
you know
so there's a lot more leniency amongst
each other you know but in prison
there's no
legacies no it's it's it's uh when you
get there they give you the verbal you
get your verbal
you know the rules and regulations and
they give you something that read has
all the rules
and those are your two warning shots
anything after this no more we're not
talking to anyone now it's just
we're gonna do with you run time you
know that at that time when i was in
prison it was like a race right a lot of
racial
uh issues you know right now that's not
so bad that racially issues the more
back that was in in caliphate and
ironwood things like that so uh
you don't have one opportunity to mess
up you messed up you're out here we we
haven't we can't afford to have no [ __ ]
ups no
no no that everybody has to be ready to
go at all times everybody has to
be thinking all the time you can't be
like oh i just woke up and i wasn't
thinking there's nothing that's good you
know
it's a lot less lenient you mean yeah
were you around for the drive-by era or
not yeah
yeah heavily yeah so drive-bys were just
for what purpose just
just gotta shoot somebody shoot someone
you know trash you at basketball during
the drive by though
uh i don't know if you see there's more
guns in the streets or what
i don't know what the reason why but
back then like everybody shot back like
now you can shoot at somebody
and they have time to shoot back at you
but back in the drive bedtimes when you
came by you shot at somebody because
they were gonna shoot right back at you
i mean most of the time you know i mean
so it wasn't like uh you're just driving
on it's like
driving for this semester stopping and
shooting somebody
you know you're expecting for them to
shoot back or like they might have
homeboys on the side of the street
or something you know i mean there's a
lot more gun play than me like now it's
not so much
you know when i was growing up in the
early 90s
early 90s especially the southeast south
cellular people would you're norwalk and
all that
it was a a lot of a lot of gay money it
was like all day every day you mean
it wasn't like at the middle of night it
was like let's go right now when school
gets out because there's
trains earbuds you know i mean there's
trains airplanes
there's traffic there wasn't here the
gunshots two three blocks away like they
will at night you know
so that was the main thing after school
going over there to my enemies
neighborhood to the high schools in
their neighborhood and the little area
they hang out with their [ __ ] just
would go over there look for them and
try to shoot them i mean
playing simple you know as an outsider
looking at the gang
world it just seems ridiculous to me
that like there can be somebody who
lives in the town next to you
who's your enemy for no good reason
other than just he's
he lives across the tracks from you well
i think did you keep your friends with
him today
you're right it is it doesn't make sense
but very few things do make sense and
other people understand on the outside
like how can you fight for the street or
fight for this fire they're not fighting
for their fight for a blood flow that
already exists because
maybe uh while you're in junior high
they killed your friend
[ __ ] michael who was from the gang
and you weren't before you though you
know maybe you know
so now you've already lost friends this
bluetooth is going on it's not even
about
this or that anyone else about they're
killing us we're going to kill them now
so that's what's
happening you know it's almost like
human nature yes
it's like for gays like tribes you know
it's like choice like tribal
warfare i mean pretty much you know
and your kids are following your dad's
footsteps no no
hell no not at all my my my biggest
mom's born and raised cattle in ireland
it means they're they're they're they're
white people i mean you know i mean i
don't really say respect for anything
but they're square people you know
they've worked all their life you know i
mean they're not they're not they're not
being raised in a bad environment at all
what do they think of their dad oh they
love me like you love me you know
they don't they don't see nothing other
but me i mean there's no me getting them
eating bottles getting up and
watching pbs with them or getting up and
putting a movie on for them that's why
they know what i mean
so you have a good relationship with
them yeah with your kids yeah yeah well
you've been since with me my since uh
uh her name is grace with me and grace
have broke up it's been a little more uh
uh she uses him a little more as sort of
tools to hurt me a little more and
she can't remember how i care less about
her numbers but now she likes to use the
kids as a way to you know
you know what i'm going to do yeah yeah
how has the gang experience like changed
since you were young
oh it's weak now it's not the same
anymore it's not the same
it's just not it's just i know i
remember when i was younger the older
guys used to say that about us
you know honestly i i know it's not just
something that's being said because you
look back and you're like man
that day we would have done this we
would have done that or or like back
then those guys couldn't have come into
our neighborhood right on the wall back
then they can do you know i mean like
things like that you know like you knew
the difference you know more loyalty the
more a lot more loyalty i mean
and you know it's funny i tell it to
people i don't understand it but i think
i blame that attitude on like [ __ ]
rap music and me on black music
through like [ __ ] everybody i'm trying
to get money for myself like throw
individualistic telling me from a gang
and be
all by yourself i mean it's not that's
not a gang mentality i mean that's a
gay mentality is lacking now we're like
one for everybody i mean everybody's
kind of like
why join a group if you want to be alone
you know
so it lacks a lot of loyalty what's the
most important lesson you've learned
am i
don't tell nobody what you're doing ever
or where you're going where you just
don't you just don't come up with
nothing
pretty much you know that's the best way
to say it yeah
where do you where do you see your life
going from here how old are you
i'm 43 43 um still young yeah
um that's hard man because you know i've
been doing jail a prison on my life man
you mean
and my dad did it my grandfather didn't
even my dad's still in prison right now
he's just something he's always doing
pretty you know
and uh my uncle's like that i look at
them i'm like [ __ ] i don't want to be 50
55 years old still going into violations
i mean i'm 43 and i can't do it anymore
i'm going there now and i'm ready like i
can't do this
people get on my nerves i can't i don't
you know i'm saying but with your record
it's gonna be hard to get a square job
right
yeah it's hard it's hard to me but
i don't worry about trying to have a job
i mean honestly i don't worry about that
because i should worry about trying to
get money however i can wherever i can
and just you know unfortunately that's
the
the
situation for myself i mean so and i
accept it for what it is you know
at the same time though i'll probably
put my fire put my habits to society and
i go to a job agency and they'll give me
a [ __ ] job and i can't go work i mean
it's not impossible for me to get a job
i mean that's
you know that's just uh to me that's big
excuses lying near me it's not really
wanting to work you know
yeah because you did a job do you do you
think
the gang direction for for a young man
is is more
a product of environment or the or the
family or the
the friends he had the the what do you
think got you into the gang or gets it
gets a young man to follow that path
because if you grew up in santa barbara
or something you you probably
yeah you've got game members coming to
santa barbara and you don't understand
that you say how do you
meet you i say it's the environment a
little bit but at the same time it's
also a
um uh
like um a lack of
not belonging somewhere you need to get
in yeah you know
life is social you mean you gotta be
part of some type of group you gotta be
you don't think i'd be
accepted by whoever you're gonna be
accepted by but you're gonna everybody
wants to be accepted by somebody you're
aware of your family
yeah so you need to you know
maybe gangs they look good to people you
mean like it makes you it looks good you
get girls whatever the [ __ ] you doing
this is doing that but i mean you know
you don't see the other side you know
you know before like you join a gang
like you're going to prison
you're from a gang you're going to
prison now there's people there's gang
members are like hoping to dodge prison
it's like that's not that's part of the
lifestyle
prison is going to happen i mean just
for how long is the question you mean
but if you're being a gang member you're
going to prison otherwise you're not
being a gang member you're just
i don't know what you're doing but
you're not being a gay member what
advice would you give to a young man
who's
considering doing this today
i'm not gonna say it's not worth it
nowadays because i don't think it was
ever really worth it
to other people it wasn't to me i i have
no
uh regrets about it to me but um
i would just say make sure it's really
what you want to do because you got to
carry that around
forever i mean you know some people
can't some people can't
some people aren't capable of the
violence that they think they are and so
they do it
and then they got to sleep with
themselves or they get some people i've
seen some people
not be able to handle the violence they
do you mean it it
affects them somehow i'm saying um
everybody thinks they can do this they
can do that but you actually have to get
up there and do and you do it how are
you gonna feel afterwards
yeah you're gonna sleep do you sleep
with yourself and after that you mean or
you know
so it's like just make sure you make
sure you're really
really ready to do you know ready to
make that take that step you know
and to control it you know once you do
take that step and you know you can take
that step
now it's a question of like having to
decide when to do that like now it's
like
it's not an issue like being both for
prideful and renounced i already know i
could do that but
what can i do and get away with it and
if i do do it what's gonna happen
afterwards or you know when i was
pushing to that it's not about uh
you know um pulling the trigger yeah
it's not just pulling the trigger no
more i mean or you know it's just
there's other things you got to
compensate you know
all right alex well thank you so much
for talking with me and uh
good luck with wherever you go from here
thank you for having me thanks man
you